Hi there, it's Marianne here. Before we dive into today's episode, I want to quickly let you know about something exciting that's happening right now. If you've ever wondered how to create income that works for you, rather than constantly trading your time for money, then you'll love the Race to Recurring Revenue Challenge with my business mentor, Lisa Johnson. This challenge is designed to help you build sustainable income streams. And whether you're an aspiring psychologist, a mental health professional, or in a completely different field,
大家好，我是Marianne。在进入今天的话题之前，我想快速向大家介绍一件正在发生的令人兴奋的事情。如果你曾经想过如何创造为你工作的收入，而不是不断地用时间换金钱，那么你一定会喜欢我商业导师Lisa Johnson发起的“迈向经常性收入挑战”（Race to Recurring Revenue Challenge）。这个挑战旨在帮助你建立可持续的收入来源。无论你是立志成为心理学家、心理健康专业人士，还是来自完全不同的领域，
the principles can work for you. There are also wonderful prizes to be won directly by Lisa herself. And if you join the challenge by my link, you can be in with a chance of winning a one-to-one hours coaching with me, Dr. Marianne Trent. Do you want to know more? Of course you do. Head to my link tree, Dr. Marianne Trent, or check out my social media channels, or send me a quick DM and I'll get you all the details. Right, let's get on with today's episode. Coming up in today's episode, I am guiding you through the five things that I am super glad that I did know as a psychology undergraduate. I hope you'll find this useful
这些原则都同样适用。此外，还有由Lisa本人直接提供的丰厚奖品。如果你通过我的链接加入挑战，你还有机会赢取与我——Marianne Trent博士一对一的辅导时间。想了解更多吗？当然想。请前往我的Linktree页面“Dr. Marianne Trent”，查看我的社交媒体频道，或者直接给我发私信，我会告诉你所有细节。好了，让我们开始今天的节目吧。在今天的节目中，我将带你了解五件我非常庆幸自己在心理学本科期间就知道的事情。希望这对你有所帮助，
whatever stage of career you are at and it is coming up right now. So stay tuned. If you're looking to become a psychologist Then let this be your guide With this podcast at your side You'll be on your way to being qualified It's the Aspiring Psychologist Podcast With Dr. Marianne Trent and I'm a qualified clinical psychologist. We recently did an episode about the five things that I wish I'd known as an undergraduate psychology student. And that got me thinking about the five things that I'm glad I
无论你处于职业生涯的哪个阶段。内容马上开始，敬请期待。如果你想成为一名心理学家，那就让这成为你的指南。有这个播客在身边，你将走上获得资格的道路。这是《有抱负的心理学家播客》（Aspiring Psychologist Podcast），我是Marianne Trent博士，我是一名合格的临床心理学家。我们最近做了一期关于“我希望在本科心理学学习期间就知道的五件事”的节目。这让我开始思考那些我庆幸自己
did know as a psychology undergraduate student. So this might well be the second half of that very recent episode, which you can watch by checking out my YouTube. I'm going to the Aspiring Psychologist podcast playlist or by scanning the QR code on screen now, heading to the Aspiring Psychologist podcast where you can listen to that yourself. Or you can come over to Apple podcasts or Spotify to listen to it directly from there or basically on my website. There's not many places that you can't stumble into either the podcast or the YouTube version of it. If you are watching on YouTube please do subscribe, like, comment, tell your friends. So let's plow on with first of the five things that I'm glad I knew as
在心理学本科期间确实知道的事情。所以这很可能是那期近期节目的下半部分，你可以通过查看我的YouTube频道、前往《有抱负的心理学家播客》播放列表，或者扫描屏幕上的二维码来观看。你也可以前往《有抱负的心理学家播客》收听。或者你也可以在Apple Podcasts或Spotify上直接收听，或者基本上在我的网站上也能找到。几乎到处都能找到这个播客或其YouTube版本。如果你正在YouTube上观看，请务必订阅、点赞、评论并告诉你的朋友。那么，让我们继续讲我庆幸自己在心理学本科期间知道的五件事中的第一件。
a psychology undergraduate. It might sound a little bit silly, but university is not just about studying. You know, I learned so much from the people I met. I learned about having fun. I learned about, you know, managing my own household, cooking, cleaning, trying my best to live with people that weren't blood related to me and not having them want to kill me, you know, and vice versa. You know, I learned a lot and, you know, about cooperation, about, you know, bill paying and, you know, sharing the bathroom with other adolescent females was interesting. Having to wait your turn, book in for, you know, the bathroom, whereas that's not something I'd experienced, you know, where I grew up with just me and my brother. So that was unique and special and
这听起来可能有点傻，但大学不仅仅是关于学习。你知道，我从遇到的人身上学到了很多。我学会了如何享受乐趣，学会了如何管理自己的家庭、做饭、打扫卫生，尽我所能与非血缘关系的人住在一起，并且不让他们想杀了我（反之亦然）。你知道，我学到了很多关于合作、支付账单的知识，而且和其他女性同龄人共用浴室也很有趣。必须等待轮到自己，或者预约使用浴室，这在我与哥哥一起长大的环境中是从未经历过的。所以那是非常独特、特别且
important. But also, you know, I guess I was busy cultivating friendships. So maybe I always knew that the people that I would spend time with in 1999 to 2002 would go on to become my lifelong friends. Not just friends for a season, not just friends for undergrad, but that, you know, in 2023 and beyond, we'd still be setting aside time in our diaries to put those times together, to make new memories and to reflect upon the old ones and that our children would grow up knowing these people and, you know, spending time with them. These are not necessarily just people for right now. These might well be, you know, certainly one of the girls that I met there was my bridesmaid,
重要的经历。但同时，我想我当时忙于培养友谊。也许我一直都知道，我在1999年到2002年间共度时光的人，将会成为我一生的朋友。不仅仅是某个阶段的朋友，不仅仅是本科期间的朋友，而是到了2023年及以后，我们仍然会在日记中留出时间聚在一起，创造新的回忆并回顾旧时光，我们的孩子也会在认识这些人的环境中长大，并与他们共度时光。这些人不一定只是当下的伙伴。他们很可能，事实上，我在那里认识的一位女孩后来成为了我的伴娘，
one of my bridesmaids at university. You know, really important people that we meet along the way in our psychology undergrad, although none of them were doing psychology undergrad. But the three friends that I was very close to when I was doing my psychology undergrad, we are still very close friends. And we've been through some real highs and lows together. So yeah, the people that I was hanging out with all the time are still in my life and I'm really pleased and really proud to say that that is the case. You know,
我大学时的伴娘之一。你知道，我们在心理学本科期间遇到的人真的很重要，尽管他们中没有人是学心理学的。但我读心理学本科时非常亲密的三个朋友，我们至今仍是挚友。我们一起经历了一些真正的高潮和低谷。所以，是的，我当时一直在一起玩的人现在仍然在我的生活中，我很高兴也很自豪地说事实确实如此。你知道，
you're learning a lot. It's not just about going to university, going to the lectures, going to the seminars, getting your essays done. Of course it's about that, but there is so much more and I think I did know that at uni. Number two that I'm glad about is that I did have quite a lot of time off in my psychology undergrad and so I knew that I had some time to be able to work whilst studying. And so work is what I did. From my second year onwards I worked with disabled students helping them to be able to access a level playing field to be able to do their lectures, I'd help them take notes or I'd help scribe in interviews or I'd help scribe in exams.
你学到了很多。这不仅仅是关于上大学、听讲座、参加研讨会、完成论文。当然这些很重要，但还有更多。我想我在大学时确实意识到了这一点。我庆幸的第二点是，我在心理学本科期间确实有很多空闲时间，所以我知道我有时间可以在学习的同时工作。所以我确实去工作了。从大二开始，我为残疾学生提供帮助，让他们能够获得公平的竞争环境来参加讲座。我会帮他们记笔记，或者在面试中做记录，或者在考试中做记录。
How they read my own writing at that point I don't know but they did manage to do it. And that might be transient disabilities, might be someone's broken arm or a leg, I'd help them get the lectures and make sure they were okay and support them. Or it might be more chronic disabilities, you know, for a variety of reasons that meant that they needed some extra support. So I learned a load from that and I really enjoyed it. And it also put extra money in my pocket, which was great. Let's take a brief break here and I'll be back along with point three, point four and point five. Let this be your guide. Filled with lessons and experience that will help you get qualified.
他们当时是怎么读懂我的字迹的，我也不知道，但他们确实做到了。这可能是暂时的残疾，比如某人手臂或腿骨折了，我会帮他们跟上讲座，确保他们没问题并支持他们。或者可能是更长期的残疾，因为各种原因需要额外的支持。所以我从中学到了很多，而且我真的很喜欢。这也让我的口袋里多了一些钱，这太棒了。让我们在这里休息一下，稍后我会回来分享第三、第四和第五点。让这成为你的指南。充满了将帮助你获得资格的经验和教训。
So come and take a look. It's right here in this book. It's the Clinical Psychologist Collective. It's the Clinical Psychologist Collective. Thank you for listening. In the first half, we were looking at the first two things that I'm really glad that I did know when I was a psychology undergraduate student. Let's crack on with point number three. I'm sort of glad that I gave myself permission to do a degree that interested me without necessarily knowing where that was going to take me, you know, just to make it quite an exploratory degree,
所以来看看吧。就在这本书里。这是《临床心理学家集体》（The Clinical Psychologist Collective）。这是《临床心理学家集体》。感谢收听。在上半部分，我们看了我非常庆幸自己在心理学本科期间知道的前两件事。让我们继续讲第三点。我很高兴自己允许自己去攻读一个我感兴趣的学位，而不必非要知道它会带我走向何方。你知道，只是把它当作一个探索性的学位，
to allow, you know, the things that I enjoyed about what I was learning to percolate through me. And then ultimately to come to me in the final weeks of term of my final year, that I thought I want to be a clinical psychologist. So if I'd realized that earlier, I might well have been able to do other things. But I think it's okay that I got there when I did and I kind of gave myself that holistic experience of being an undergrad student. I think if I'd realized about clinical psychology before, I might have felt much more pressure and it might have felt much more competitive and I might have burned myself out.
让我在学习中享受的东西渗透到我的内心。最终在最后一学年的最后几周，我意识到我想成为一名临床心理学家。所以如果我早点意识到这一点，我可能就能做其他事情了。但我认为在我那个时候意识到这一点也没关系，我给了自己作为本科生那种全面的体验。我想如果我早点意识到临床心理学，我可能会感到更大的压力，竞争感会更强，我可能会让自己精疲力竭。
So I'm kind of pleased that I just took it all as it came and got my assignments done, had fun with my friends and then fell, you know, fell into, stumbled across clinical psychology when the time was right for me. Point number four, I'm actually really glad that I knew that actually for me, using my university vacations over the summer was a great idea to be able to work, to be able to gain some extra money. I did quite like shopping in Topshop at those times. And so when I was at university, it was nice to be able to have some money to afford noodles, food, you know, the odd pint of beer. I'm not really a very good beer drinker, but, you know, sometimes I used to drink that and
所以我很高兴我只是顺其自然，完成了我的作业，和朋友们玩得很开心，然后在合适的时机偶然发现了临床心理学。第四点，我其实很高兴自己知道，对我来说，利用暑假期间去工作是一个赚取额外收入的好主意。那时候我挺喜欢在Topshop购物的。所以当我在大学时，能有一些钱来买面条、食物，偶尔喝杯啤酒真是太好了。我其实不太会喝啤酒，但你知道，有时我也会喝那个，还有
vodka, lemonade and lime. I can't think what else I used to drink. Martini. No, not martini. I can't think what else I used to drink. I have to ask my university friends on the next season what I used to drink. work either as a home carer or to work in boots chemist to earn some money to be able to pay off my overdraft you have to pay a chunk of my tuition fees as well so yeah I knew that and I'm glad because it gave me structure it meant that I didn't just use the whole of my summer vacations to just sleep you know and I wouldn't have been able to go out and socialize at all over my university holidays if I hadn't worked because of course I needed money have been able to go out and socialize at all over my university holidays if I hadn't worked because of course I needed money to be able to do those things as well. So for me, working was a really sensible thing to do. Working in Boots the Chemist meant that I learned a great deal about working with others
伏特加、柠檬水和青柠。我想不出我还喝过什么。马提尼。不，不是马提尼。我想不出我还喝过什么。我得在下一季问问我的大学朋友我以前喝什么。要么做家庭护理员，要么在Boots药店工作来赚钱，以便还清我的透支款，还得支付一部分学费。所以是的，我知道这一点，我很高兴，因为它给了我结构。这意味着我不会把整个暑假都用来睡觉。如果我不工作，我就无法在大学假期里出去社交，因为我当然需要钱才能做这些事情。所以对我来说，工作是一件非常明智的事情。在Boots药店工作意味着我学到了很多关于与他人合作的知识，
and customer service and teamwork, know, teamwork, you know, helping make things harmonious. And that leads us nicely into point five, really, which is what I've called teamwork makes the dream work. And that's about that holistic experience of learning from others, you know, watching them grow, watching ourselves grow, you know, knowing that we're all in this together and that there's something very special about a cohort and, you know, watching that development across a cohort is really, really special. You know, and we used to draw upon each other's strength
以及客户服务和团队合作。你知道，团队合作，帮助事情变得和谐。这很好地引出了第五点，我称之为“团队合作成就梦想”（teamwork makes the dream work）。这是关于从他人身上学习的全面体验，看着他们成长，看着我们自己成长，知道我们都在一起，而且一个群体（cohort）有一些非常特别的东西，看着整个群体的成长真的非常非常特别。你知道，我们过去常常利用彼此的力量
and skills to help us to understand things better. But also, you know, when it came to lectures, across the four of us, one of us would definitely be there. And so we would share lecture notes for any lectures that we hadn't been to. And I'm sure in modern day universities, you know, attending is a bit easier if you're able to do it online and probably lecture notes are all available as a download at the click of a button. But in my day when I was studying you had to go take actual pen and paper. There was probably only one person that had
和技能来帮助我们更好地理解事物。而且，当涉及到讲座时，我们四个人中肯定会有一个人在场。所以我们会分享那些我们没去听的讲座的笔记。我相信在现代大学里，如果你能在线上课，出勤会更容易一些，而且讲座笔记可能只需点击一下按钮就能下载。但在我学习的那个年代，你必须去拿真正的纸和笔。当时可能只有一个人有
a laptop in those days and they were seen as very fancy. They're one that you could take out with you and type in a lecture. So, yeah, teamwork most definitely made the green work and yeah, just really special memories of all the cohort that I trained with. So, has this evoked any memory sports reflections for you? Has it enabled you to reflect on where you're at right now in your career as an aspiring psychologist? I would love to know what you think. Come and let me know on the Aspiring Psychologist Community free Facebook group. Please do also consider joining the Inspiring Psychologist membership where we really help supercharge your abilities, your skills, your potential across a wide range of things from formulation to research to personal reflections and across a wide
笔记本电脑，而且它们被视为非常时髦。那是你可以带出去并在讲座中打字的电脑。所以，是的，团队合作绝对成就了梦想。对于我一起训练的整个群体，我有着非常特别的回忆。那么，这是否唤起了你的任何记忆或反思？它是否让你反思了作为一名有抱负的心理学家，你目前在职业生涯中所处的位置？我很想知道你的想法。来“有抱负的心理学家社区”免费Facebook群组告诉我吧。也请考虑加入“有抱负的心理学家会员计划”，我们在这里真正帮助你提升能力、技能和潜力，涵盖从构思（formulation）到研究，再到个人反思等广泛领域，以及广泛的
range of different therapeutic orientations. It gets great reviews. We'd love to see you in there and to really continue that theme of teamwork and making the dream work that really is what happens in the membership. I will look forward to catching up with you for the next episode of the Aspiring Psychologist podcast, which will be along for you from 6am on Monday. Thank you so much for being part of my world. I will look forward to catching up with you very soon. Take care. If you're looking to become a psychologist, then let this be your guide.
不同治疗取向。它获得了很好的评价。我们很乐意在里面见到你，并真正延续团队合作和成就梦想的主题，这确实是会员计划中正在发生的事情。我期待在下一期《有抱负的心理学家播客》中与你相见，节目将于周一早上6点发布。非常感谢你成为我世界的一部分。我期待很快与你再会。保重。如果你想成为一名心理学家，那就让这成为你的指南。
With this podcast at your side, you'll be on your way to being qualified. It's the Aspiring a trainee psychological wellbeing practitioner. I read the Clinical Psychologist Collective book. I found it really interesting about all the different stories and how people got to become a clinical psychologist. It just amazed me how many different routes there are to get there and there's no perfect way to become one and this kind of filled me with confidence that no I'm not doing it wrong and put less pressure on myself. So if you're feeling a bit uneasy about becoming a clinical psychologist I'd definitely recommend
有这个播客在身边，你将走上获得资格的道路。这是《有抱负的心理学家》，一位心理健康从业者学员。我读了《临床心理学家集体》这本书。我发现关于所有不同的故事以及人们如何成为临床心理学家的经历真的很有趣。有多少种不同的途径可以达到目标让我感到惊讶，没有完美的途径可以成为一名临床心理学家，这让我充满了信心，觉得我并没有做错，也减轻了自己的压力。所以如果你对成为一名临床心理学家感到有点不安，我绝对推荐
this just to put yourself at ease and everything will be okay. But trust me you will not put the book down once you start. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
这本书，它会让你感到安心，一切都会好起来的。但相信我，一旦你开始读，你就不会放下这本书。此剧集暂无评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。